Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two. David P. I
don't like the voicemail. I'm about to play for
you. I think the caller is calling me racist.
A couple of days ago, I said Oprah bears
some responsibility for unleashing Dr. Oz
Mehmet Oz onto the world. And this caller, I
think, is saying I'm racist for saying that.
Speaker 5: Hello. I'm so confused as
myself because I can't believe I'm calling,
but something you say really annoyed me, and to
be honest, I normally just ignore these asides by
certain demographic certain demographics.
Speaker 1: Oh, it sounds like because I appear
to be white. I said the wrong thing,
Speaker 5: because if they don't
have black friends or anything like, maybe they
just don't get it. Well-meaning as they might be,
they might just say anyway, I was really surprised
to hear you use the Oprah thing and say the real
question is why Oprah unleashed many girls into
the world. Blah blah blah. Yeah. And I realize
you said you were joking. A lot of people say
that and then say they're joking. It's not a
joke. Oprah is not responsible for anything to do
with these people and their views on all of this.
She had a production company, I believe, and
hired people based on shows that could make money.
Nobody blames Mark Burnett for Donald Trump.
Speaker 1: Actually, a lot of people do. A
lot of people do. A lot of people say if Mark
Burnett had never given Trump the apprentice,
Trump never would have become president. So
that's right. But listen, here's the thing, guys.
Oprah being black has nothing to do with why I
said she's responsible for unleashing Mehmet Oz
way before. Years before Mehmet Oz got the Dr.
Oz show produced by Oprah. Oprah invited Dr. Oz
onto her show more than 60 times. OK, so this has
nothing to do with race. And of course, if Oprah
invites someone 60 times and they have no popular
appeal, they're not going to all of a sudden be
a viable Senate candidate. But Oprah, as as she
has launched the careers of many people. I mean,
listen, Oprah's responsible for Dr. Phil. I would
argue who, by the way, is not a psychologist.
It it's it has nothing to do with race. Oprah
is responsible for many people being well known.
Mehmet Oz is one of them. Dr. Phil McGraw
is another one of them. And that's it.
It's this is this is the exact, you know, I say
this stuff is not really common on the left,
but sometimes you see it. This is the stuff
that just I it's race related that I said
Oprah's responsible for Mehmet Oz. Give me
a break, guys, give me a break. It's not
this ain't it. As the kids these days like to say,
we have a great bonus show for you today. Producer
Pat will be making his triumphant return to the
bonus show after a few days off. We are going
to talk about the horrible shooting in the New
York subway. We'll tell you what is now known.
Shanghai China residents who are screaming from
their windows during lockdown are getting visits
from drones, warning them about their behavior.
And we will also talk about new allegations that
Elon Musk, by delaying the announcement
of the stake he purchased in Twitter,
saved a bundle on his taxes. All of those
stories and more will be addressed in a
serious manner today on the bonus show. You can
get instant access to the bonus show by signing
up at joint Packman dot com. Don't miss it! And
if you already have a membership, you can gift a
membership gift a membership at join Pacman dot
com. Lastly, Tuesday, April 19th at six p.m.,
we'll be doing the next David Pakman Show Viewer
Town Hall. Everybody is welcome to call in
will be streaming the town hall live on our second
YouTube channel. That's the Pacman Live YouTube
channel. Hope to see you there! And remember that
everybody is welcome to call in, but our website
members will get a priority line to call it.
Unidentified: Sign up at Join Tottenham dot com.